who would be worried in this
situation I take it I I give the
exchange no worries no worries I take
the PA push it push it baby he's
confused look at him the guy is
completely flustered he did has no idea
how to play this position and my pawns
my pawns they are running they're
running indeed my they are running so
fast wow look at this and I have to be a
little bit careful now uh okay I'll do
this I do this you can you can take it
you can take it I'm winning back
material and for the first time in the
game I'm of material look at this and
he's spending so much time a few moments
later taking the bishop but is it going
to be fast
enough
o and he's lost on time another one for
me